is silenced the grief is immeasurable
the pain almost too much to bear
known by many as the daughter of
Palestine the veteran Al Jazeera
journalist was shot dead by Israeli
forces in the occupied West Bank on
Wednesday while on an assignment in the
city of Janine
for her friends and colleagues the loss
has been devastating
she was born and raised
in in Jerusalem on their occupation she
was telling the story that she was
living every day she was not just
telling the story of the people she was
telling the story the story of her life
as well and this is what made her
magically
and I couldn't
was one of Al jazeera's first field
correspondence having joined the channel
in 1997.
covering the second into father didn't
just turn her into a household name it
also transformed her into a role model
on the air the palestinian-american
Trailblazer showcased the power of
Journalism
while off the air she taught journalism
classes inspiring women and men to
always speak truth to power
for many of the younger journalists in
fact for most of us she was an idol
somebody we would look up to
she knows her facts she knows the story
she knows how to connect to people she
was sincere she loved what she did
thousands came out on Friday and
occupied East Jerusalem to pay their
respects
but earlier as the funeral procession
began at the Saint Joseph Hospital in
the neighborhood they were confronted
with the ultimate sign of disrespect
as mourners were attacked by Israeli
forces Paul bearers struggled to prevent
shireen's coffin from hitting the ground
people were pulled out of the hearse
Israeli forces also removed the
Palestinian flag
everyone was their support there to to
show their support and love and at the
end of the day even in her death
she was not she wasn't done peacefully
even the day of the funeral was
it was violence
the funeral procession later resumed and
reached a cathedral in the Christian
quarter of the old city
where a service was held before Shireen
was laid to rest next to her parents
gravesite at the Mount Zion Protestant
Cemetery
she went into the hearts of every single
Palestinian and I dare say every Arab
household because of her touching
reporting and the way that she had of
bringing to life the reality of Israel's
brutal occupation
in her reporting
combined unwavering strength and
steadfast empathy
telling the story of her people as
clearly and thoughtfully as possible her
voice may have gone silent but it will
continue to reverberate
Al Jazeera
[Applause]
well International and Palestinian
journalistic organizations media
organizations they launched an
accusation a case a formal complaint in
the international criminal court last
month accusing Israel of committing war
crimes against journalists the committee
to protect journalists says 24 not
including Sharina bakla have been killed
in Israel and the occupied Palestinian
territory since 2002 other press Freedom
Advocates have reported even higher
numbers
well Israel systematically targets
journalists including Al Jazeera has
been the finding of several human rights
groups in 2010 it detained several
onboard a humanitarian flotilla heading
to Gaza last year Israel bombed a
building with media offices including Al
Jazeera in the occupied Gaza Strip and
barely a month later Israeli forces
arrested Al Jazeera of journalist javada
borderi and she covered a demonstration
in the neighborhood of occupied East
Jerusalem
well earlier I spoke to Pierre haskey
he's the president of reporters Without
Borders and I asked him about these
kinds of events
I convey my condolences for the tragic
deaths of of Shireen no it hasn't and
it's uh the requirement are not there
we've been calling and many people have
been calling for an international
investigation to go to the bottom of of
this case we have some experiences
already you know 35 journalists have
been killed in Israel and Palestine in
the past 20 years and none of the
investigations carried out by the
Israeli Army jump in if I could because
you mentioned something really
interesting there you've said that
you've been calling on Israel to allow
an international investigation what kind
of response do you get from Israeli
authorities to that kind of request is
there any indication that they would be
open to an international investigation
to cooperate with it
no there's no indication yet uh the the
Israeli authorities have been giving the
usual response that they are conducting
their own investigation but uh we all
feel whether it's the U.N security call
yesterday uh the U.S state Department or
ngos like ours have been calling for an
independent inquiry and that cannot be
solely from the Israeli Army and there's
no sign yet that the that Israel is
ready to comply but we think that the
pressure is unprecedented on this case
and we're hoping that the Israeli
authorities will change their mind on
this independent inquiry what do you
make of how the Israeli position has
evolved over time at the beginning we
heard statements from Israeli officials
were kind of pointing the blame in
direction of the Palestinians since then
their statements have kind of taken a
different direction to include at least
in their minds the possibility that they
did actually kill Shireen
yes I think it has followed the kind of
usual path in the in the sense that the
immediate and automatic response is to
blame the Palestinians for what happened
they probably underestimated at that
point the outcry that it would generate
worldwide and certainly it has forced
the Israeli authorities to pull back on
this initial statement and at least
leave the door open for their own
responsibility if the investigation goes
through but it's not enough and and as I
said earlier we need an independent
inquiry but it's a good sign that the
authorities in Israel have been
responding to the the pressure on their
initial statement which was really
baseless all right you mentioned a
moment ago there's been no indication
that Israel will be open to an
international inquiry without the
internationalization of the
investigation what does that mean for
the chances of accountability
International presence I think there
will be
we have to be very clear about that and
it's very interesting that in in the
midst of the Ukraine war and the
attention that we have an idea when
viewers are listening why
because the the records for the past 20
years for the 35 journalists who have
been killed in particularly in the
Palestinian territories has been no
accountability never not for a single
case so we have no reason to believe
that this will be different this time
and and it's very interesting that in
the middle of the international
divisions the U.N security Council was
able to produce a unanimous statement
calling for an immediate transparent and
thorough investigation into this case so
I think the the level of international
Consciousness on on this case is is
quite unprecedented and I don't think uh
Israel we can get away with it
well I've got to ask you one more
question since it is also the one year
anniversary since the destruction of
that media building housing the
facilities of Al Jazeera an Associated
Press how much progress has there been
towards any sense of Investigation
transparency or accountability for that
there's been no progress to be honest
that can be spoken of because
Israel says it's a you know it's The Miz
of the war it doesn't take into account
that targeting a media building is
considered a war crime and is
contradicting every international law
resolution that exists particularly
resolution 2222 of the U.N security
Council from 2015 which states clearly
that journalists should be treated as
civilians and therefore cannot be a
Target in a war so this is very clear
and there's been no sign yet there again
of any accountability